hugh i want to start with you
do you think that keller got out of the
pit in prisoners
yes yes
it feels pretty clear to me i'm going to
be honest people say that to me all the
time i'm like
the last frame of the movie is him
turning when he hears the whistle
for sure we actually shot we shot the
scene
uh it was in the script we shot the
scene of him coming and telling me
the news about my daughter and then
in the end everyone thought well then
everyone's going to be like it's not
there's no like it's a weird ending
because he's going to job for 20 years
so it's sort of like
oh wow so i think that's what from
memory that's that's what happened there
but people said it to me all the time
i'm like
yeah he did i agree
as a viewer no no i i think so as well
but
people like to know they like to you
know anyway moving on
lisa my question for you is um do you
sleep
because you have a family kids and
multiple projects
and i really want to know how you pull
this off and she plays a piano like a
fiend
just fyi i don't sleep i defeated the
need for sleep when i had children i was
like now i have
it was like how i want you to clone
himself i now have nightmare and damie
and then and then there's no i get like
maybe three hours a night
i do you ever sleep more than that do
you ever get like a
like a crazy go for 15 hours for the
catch-up thing
no because if i if i'm not working then
the kids are like
jumping on top of me there's never
there's never more than like three or
four hours
i'm aging exponentially quickly
uh hugh i'm curious what is the secret
to maintaining your voice
when you are performing eight
performances a week
ah live like a monk basically live like
a monk
i uh i'm really boring well devil will
tell you i'm boring a lot of the time
but i never go out after the show
i make sure i sleep drink a lot uh
of water not the other drinking
unfortunately except sunday nights
um and i still have a single lesson once
a week
and do proper warm-ups worn down like
it's just
unfortunately there's no easy road
around it
lisa jumping back to you i read
something and i need to know if this is
true
that of the way you broke into the
industry you were studying to
like the you wrote a spec script can you
talk about how you broke in the industry
yeah i was um i had
uh been sent to law school by this
company mckinsey
and um when i was studying but i had to
go back to be a management consultant
for them to
pay off my law school debt so while i
was studying for the california
bar i completely panicked and was like
it was mostly about pantyhose i was very
concerned that i would have to wear
pantyhose for the rest of my life in
like an
ann taylor suit and like those like just
asphyxiate your crotch they're just so
uncomfortable and i don't think people
wear them as much now but they did
and in my desperation to avoid
a life consigned to pantyhose wearing i
i wrote um
my first uh tv script and then
i wanted to be an assistant but some
weird thing happened where they
um they staffed me and i found out when
i was on a study in
in san francisco i was i was working in
high tech at the time
which i guess came in handy for
westworld and such but um i had to
quit on the spot and come back and then
i had to i had so much
law school debt but i managed to pay it
off like two years ago
yeah yeah it was about two years ago
night lisa wrote and david's uh was it
mckinsey
yes exactly and i wrote mostly poetry
until
jonah got me software and was like
you're never gonna make a living off of
poetry which is unfortunately true
yeah if i could very inelegantly segue
for reminiscence is quite poetic so
there you go
it is it is when we're following your
voice it could have been
left i remember by the way the first
time we cut the trailer
when we we hadn't sold the
film yet and we put together sizzle for
berlin and you know we had all these
like artwork and concept art and my team
and i were looking at it and then hugh
was kind enough to record
the voiceover for it and there was just
like
swooning in the halls they were like
what how does his voice alone just do
that it's just elevated i was like
that's because he's hugh jackman and
he's like
doing the thing this is the whole reason
why we need hugh jackman
so what was mulder prima
i promise last question before we're
going to get to uh the film which i have
a ridiculous amount of questions um hugh
i'm curious
you you play in a lot of films you've
played a lot of obsessed people
and uh you've given a lot to your
performances what was the
toughest one to let go of the toughest
character to let go of
after you wrapped filming like in terms
of you know
because i'm sure some of who you play
comes with you
um home at the end of the day or maybe
i'm completely wrong
blame is let miserable i think there was
something
so about the process it was very
intense and as the title suggests it's
not many really happy
scenes in it so um and it just was a
really
deep place i would say les mis was the
hardest i'm not
a method actor by any stretch but i
think that was the one that was hardest
to
just get back into normal life when you
were
when you were done shooting reminiscence
did you go home to deb and talk in
voiceover
tonight we're searching for turkey
meatloaf yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh one of the things that i love about
this movie is that it's an original
piece of ip
it's not based on existing material it's
not a sequel
it is really hard to make these movies
nowadays
lisa how the f did you pull this off
uh just add hugh jackman that's gonna be
my answer
to everything i mean hugh i
i basically wrote hugh a
fan letter i asked my agent
my my family had uh had worked with hugh
before and loved him but
you know somebody asked me this before
they were like did you use that
connection i'm like how
weirded out would you have been it's
like i'm the wife of the
brother of the director you once worked
with and i really like every time
it's like this that's not gonna go well
but what will go well is a crazy person
fan letter to you talking about
how i've written this script and only he
will do
and then i was so high maintenance that
i refused to send him the script
i was like yeah i'll just pop by i'm
just in the in the neighborhood i can
pop by any time i was in
la he was in new york and so when he was
like
i was like you know travelocity get me
an overnight flight
get me to new york so i can pop by and
tell him about the script um
and but no in all honesty it was it
truly was
uh i told my agent i'm like well if it's
not you i'm not going to do it and then
no one's going to do it because i don't
want anyone else to do it now
so and so they were like you don't mean
that and i was like no i
i 100 mean that so i'm glad you said yes
and and you
saying yes um it just you know to be
basically a complete indie we didn't
have a studio we didn't have anything
like that
um and we just went to berlin and having
hugh as an ally um it made it a real for
me and i think certainly real for other
people as well
thank you for saying that by the way but
you'd had that script sitting there for
a while
like before westworld i remember you
telling me that you said i know
i wrote it but i know i won't be able to
get it made i need to have
some runs on the board i think you said
i have to have something else and then
then i'll do it yeah you knew that in
advance
when i wrote it you know the script was
really well received again it was just a
on the open market
so so there were a couple interested
parties and with that i was able to
leverage
control over it you know so um in terms
of just how it was presented as
a producer which is something that not a
lot of writers have um
and just benefit of the bargain i guess
and um
and so because of that there were other
people who at times wanted to
do it but i never i don't think i ever
really bought into
their vision and it took me a while to
realize it was because i had such a
specific vision
of my own um and even though
you know i'm so grateful to them all for
their interest and everything i just um
so it just kind of stayed with me for
for a long time and percolated that way
and then after i directed
a westworld i was like time to send a
crazy letter to hugh
i'm glad he did what one of the
one of the things that the film does um
it it talks about what's going on
with our environment without batting you
over the head
um can you sort of talk about the why
you wanted
that aspect you know you know what i
mean to showcase what
probably is going to be happening to our
planet
yeah i mean for me it's a grounded film
and i wanted people to really relate
emotionally to it and i didn't
want it to be dystopian necessarily but
also you know part of
part of being a writer is you just soak
up the world you live in and you
understand
there are elements you can't deny and
you try to find ways to
um convey them without them being
you know necessarily divisive or
depressing by by basically presenting
them as the facts that they are in a
sort of matter-of-fact way like this is
happening there's no doubt
you know it isn't a movie about that but
it's a movie that has to acknowledge
that
that is a part of this world now and
it's the same thing like when people ask
about westworld like they talk about
were you responding to like the metoo
movement or whatever and i'm like no
like i've written that before that but
we all live in this world we understand
things that are happening in this world
and they inform what we do it doesn't
mean
i don't like it when things are didactic
you know to me this is
a love story and a thriller um but i
wanted to ground it in reality
it was actually uh articles while we
were shooting steve
i can't remember where i was but there
was an article basically talking about
miami going to be a few feet under water
in 20 years what remember that and also
venice
was square was completely flooded so
it was sort of happening literally while
we were shooting remember those giant
dams that we would roll onto sets to
block off the roads that that howard
made
um now miami literally i was looking at
the new york times they have dams that
look exactly like that that they're
actually using and building to stop the
water it was it was a few weeks ago
it was a front page article it was crazy
one of the things that i've learned
about after talking to many different
people in the industry
is everyone likes to work a different
way on set some actors like you know
silence some actors love to have a good
time some directors
want silence on set and others are
blasting music
what for each of you what surprised you
about the
way the other person worked or
just if you want to share the way you
like to work on set
lisa's directed before and written a lot
it was her first feature film and i was
i i knew how prepared she was so i was
not surprised by that but i was
surprised at how
much fun we had how relaxed it was how
much laughter there was and said
i think a lot of the scenes were really
intense it is a love story
my character certainly has a very
obsessive side and there was
some really sort of emotional scenes but
the atmosphere on set
was very relaxed that you and tandaway
and then with rebecca and i there was a
lot of laughter
um everyone from crew knew exactly what
they were doing that that sort of
surprised
me i'll be honest that's how i like to
watch it
i thought you were going to say you were
surprised by how many hot dogs i could
eat a day because i was up to like
six you know opening craft services
yeah i remember you and kendall looking
at me once and being like how
you eat like that what is happening
you don't have to say yes when they
bring them around like you don't every
time
no you do that's that's how i don't
sleep i'm fueled solely by by hot dogs
and the amount of times you sang
baby shark you got it there it is baby
shark
was my go-to get amped thing
when there was no coffee available i
would sing
baby shark doo doo doo doo baby shark
doo doo doo doo baby
because my kids would sing the song it
would get stuck in my head
and i knew for instance if we were
losing light and i started to sing baby
shark it has a kind of frenetic
tempo to it but it's also incredibly
annoying
so all the lighting people would work
faster everybody would just
really go because if nothing else it
would stop me from singing
baby shark yeah lisa steve the first day
of shooting
we were shooting the action sequence
with daniel in the bar
uh with handaway being amazingly cool
and stunts and a lot of things and
literally there's the first shot one of
the first shots of the film we got in a
close-up
of tandaway and there's dripping water
coming down we realized there's a
massive leak
and the roof is leaking in shot so
like that was day one and then in the
second or third week the reminiscence
machine which is
the first time lisa you should talk
about this by the way because a lot of
steve's followers will love it but
it's the first time ever that kind of
in-camera effect
had ever been done that whole hologram
effect and
it was a little difficult the first few
days god it was a pain in the ass
yeah but you were surprisingly
supremely calm trust me when i've seen
directed
when things are going wrong and
schedules seem to be blowing out in your
first days
right which you didn't by the way i've
seen people lose their [ __ ] completely
and you never did
oh well thank you i mean you know the
thing the thing is about seth from from
my part the thing that surprised me
didn't really surprise me about you like
i could tell when we talked about the
character
there were so many things that i wanted
in bannister and there was a reason why
i was drawn to him right drawn to hue
like i was like
he looks like a hero and he's this
archetypal heroic handsome
action star but we're going to go on a
journey that kind of peels back some of
these
ideas of what masculinity and what like
the kind of noir ideas of
a hero and a villain are we're going to
try to modernize that and and bring a
little more nuance into it and you're
not always going to be
necessarily the hero it's not always
going to be pretty right but
if there is love there that means it's
going to be earned right um
and he immediately got what i was
talking about
and without any kind of vanity or
thinking about
you know a lot of actors you know they
have to really think about what's my
image and what's this and hugh
is essentially a character actor in an
incredibly good looking package
like it's it's weird um
but true right and and he's super deb
this is totally platonic that but i am
you know you marry
you know what's up um but the skill that
he has
in his physical acting right like even
like the way he walks
the tiniest little affects you can tell
he dials a man beforehand and he's just
so
specific and so skilled on everything so
the reason i was able to do this
on this schedule and not lose my [ __ ]
when things went wrong and
things always go wrong with tech and
weather and yada
yada is because everybody like hugh
was he's in almost every scene he has so
much to do
so much action so much dialogue so much
emotion and he was always ready
and he would stay on set with me between
takes to save time
he got half naked on a train in miami
for me to save time because we couldn't
afford to stop and get a changing room
it was like you know but it's that kind
of collaboration that
you can't make a film like this that
attempts to have scope but also be
an original film without
like the 110 support of
of your actors and that's that's the
only reason i made it through
some movies turn out so much better in
the editing room than you can ever
expect in other movies
you're like what happened how did the
film ultimately come together in the
editing room
was what were the battles you needed to
overcome to sort of put it all together
the initial cup was long as all initial
cuts are but i was working with mark
yoshikawa who's
brilliant and you know i liked working
with him because he worked with both
malik
and with francis lawrence right and i
was like well i want to have the kind of
artistry and the sensuality of some of
malik's work
that kind of quiet unspoken uh pace and
beauty but i also want to juxtapose it
with
you know adrenaline-fueled you know
awesomeness and so to be able to combine
those two flavors i knew i needed
an editor who who could really speak
both languages and mark was perfect at
that
um you know i i feel like when i'm
writing
um i tend to have well here you can
speak to this like
i tend to have the scenes pre-cut in my
head a lot of the time
um like blocked out and the way we shot
this especially because of the hologaze
um the the because we did the hologram
practically
i had to shoot those scenes beforehand
also imagining the composition of the
final what i call the turducken
when that scene was playing and he was
orbiting around it so composition would
be something that
you couldn't see in camera because you
had to imagine in the future
um how everything was going to lay out
so it you know
happily for for for this project it was
good to have
um have that penchant for
editing it together in my head and then
you know of course
with mark's artistry we found all sorts
of
new and beautiful things to add to it
but i generally do
keep a cut in my head that stays pretty
true
there's a quite i it's now famous on set
is that online i don't know lisa but
there's a very famous sort of
in my head it's like a split screen
right of lisa on the set of westworld
talking through with the crew must be
the day before or the morning of
so it's without the actors but
explaining to everyone how this gunfire
action scene is going to go down and
it's like savant
fast quick explaining the plot the
emotional thing and you're going to
catch that over there we're going to get
it upshot we move around here we go back
and it's over to ed harris who's going
to look we're going to do a close up and
go back and she's moving through the
entire scene explaining it and
everyone's just taking notes
it's about two minutes long and next to
it is the actual finished cut scene
it's exactly as described in like
the best two minute monologue you've
ever heard so lisa's not joking when she
says it's
kind of pre-cut but were there things
that surprised you hugh when you saw it
in the end were there were you like wait
a second
no when you were thinking i was i was
just i really got very
few surprises at all i think obviously
you know the scope of the world was
something that was really fun to see and
and
by the way i encourage anyone watching
this if you have an opportunity to see
it
at an imax see it because it's simple
and it's really big and beautiful and it
was lovely to see all of that
i've gone back again i did not answer
your question but
i've never had an experience as an actor
being on set with the reminiscence
machine how beautiful that was
that existed for real it is photographed
in camera
and it's an accident i'm standing there
watching this thing some of the best
acting i did in the movie was
just looking like oh this is every day i
go to work in this machine it's another
day you know
and i don't know you know because it was
one of the most beautiful things i ever
saw but
no not too many surprises it was amazing
on the day watching you
interact with it i mean the reason you
know steve
when we started this i i think i
thankfully i have this incredible crew
who is i suppose as masochistic
as i am because i was like we are going
to make this machine
and they're like that doesn't exist if
holograms existed they would be all over
the place in this world
they are fiction and i was like yeah but
they can be real enough to be shot in
camera you know and so dimensionalizing
it the way that we had to holograms have
been
filmed in a sort of planar way before
right where you kind of look but it's
more two-dimensional but we wanted to be
able to interact with it and circle it
in three dimensions right and also to do
it in camera
and so that because hugh so much of your
so many reveals happen and so much
actual emotion has to happen
that it would be very hard to have done
it without that because even
the eye line would have constantly
changed because we would have to we
couldn't have just used a tennis ball
right we would have to like move the
tennis ball and make the tennis ball
go all over the place so we had no
choice but to
but to contend with that crazy crazy
stuff
hugh before because i'm out of time but
i am curious of the films that you've
made
which of them do you think changed the
most in the editing room
versus what you thought you were making
if any
x-men one that makes sense a week
i'm probably speaking out of school
steve but a week before i came out
i think it was 47 minutes longer
wait what wow
a week
i may be exaggerating or under exa it
was a lot
like and and maybe the week is an
exaggeration but
i certainly that's what we shot
i remember going what happened to that
scene in that character
whoa and that movie from memory is about
100 minutes i think
wow um it was a lot longer
a lot longer so that was definitely a
big surprise to me
release the full cut you know
you know what's interesting about that
though and i don't think people are
going to remember
and again i know i have to go um but
that was when the superhero genre was
not what it is now that film was one of
the
one of the reasons the superhero genre
exists today
and people won't remember but the studio
was not enthusiastic
about it in the way that they are now
that was like a battle
to get that home made oh yeah and to get
it out there were battles all the way
through
for sure and i remember people who i
knew in hollywood not my
not patrick and not anyone at the studio
but
two or three other people who were in
the know were like dude
i finished in february and it came out
july they were like
make sure you get another job like the
word on the street is this thing is a
dud
and it's okay you're you're only at the
moment you're a lead in a movie in
hollywood
right no one don't tell them it's comic
book that means nothing just say you
you're leading the movie and you at
least going to get auditions
and then try and book something before
it comes out and give you one more shot
that was i remember getting that advice
i'm like all right let's get auditioning
[Laughter]
and how how wrong i mean listen uh i
heard before
mad max fury road came out that the film
was a mess people were like bad mouthing
it and
look what that movie turned into you
know like every sometimes the buzz on
the street
is so not true never been against george
miller
never thank you both so much for talking
with me
and you know i wish you guys nothing but
the best in this film
and uh the fact is that uh i do think
that
in this moment you guys coming out on in
theaters and hbo max is actually
um a good thing even though i know you'd
rather people see it
in theatrical just because there's a lot
of people that don't feel
safe going to a theater and i think that
people will watch it
you know what i mean as long as people
feel safe and are
safe watching it you know then i'm happy
if they watch it i'm happy if anybody
connects to it
i will be hiding somewhere actually
that's what's going to happen so i'm
going to go hide if anybody knows any
good hidey holes i'm
i'm looking for one casa vega ventura
boulevard
in los angeles it's kind of close to my
house but
we can try